>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Michael Socolow: Let
me begin by welcoming you
and this is a different panel
because, as you've seen,
most of the conference
has really been focused
on public media.
And Sam Berlowski, in the
transcription one, made a joke,
he said about two people
remember who Frank Stanton was
and the CBS archive has
come up in a couple of times
and a couple of ways in there.
And it is the 50th anniversary
of Public Broadcasting,
but this is a place
that we're here to talk
about what commercial
broadcasting means in terms
of radio preservation in
that way and how it works.
Okay, so the panel is Dr.
Noah Arceneaux is an associate
professor in the school of --
when I say your name
acknowledge, please --
is an associate professor
in the school of Journalism
and Media Studies at San
Diego State University.
His PhD from the University
of Georgia examines the role
of department stores
during the early years
of American broadcasting and
his subsequent research --
and, by the way, if you haven't
read his article on technology
and culture on Wanamaker Stores
in the early nineteen teens,
it's terrific -- his subsequent
research has explored the social
construction of new media
technologies as well
as emerging forms
of mobile media.
He's the coeditor of,
in Academic Studies,
of Cell Phones, the
Cell Phone Reader,
and in 2012 he added an update
titled The Mobile Media reader,
Dr. Arceneaux spent the
spring of 2014 in India
on a Fullbright-Nehru
research grant and prior
to joining academia, Dr.
Arceneaux produced websites
for ABC, CBS, and the
FOX television networks.
Although she's a respondent,
she's actually going to go next
after Dr. Arceneaux
is Heather Birks.
Heather Birks has been
the executive director
of the Broadcast Education
Association since 2006.
Before coming to BEA she worked
for the NAB for four years
and the NABEF for six where
she helped to build, manage,
and produce the Service to
America Awards and launched
and ran the Broadcast
Leadership Training Program.
Birks oversees BEA's
partnerships
and coordinates BEA's annual
convention: The Festival
of Media Arts, and the regional
BEA On Location conferences.
She works closely with the Radio
Advertising Borough and NAB
to run the Radio Show
Student Scholars program,
which assists students
interested in careers in radio,
and in June 2017
Birks was named one
of Radio Inc's 2017 Most
Influential Women in Radio.
Professor Kathy Fuller-Seeley is
the William P. Hobby Centennial
Professor of Communication
in the Radio Television Film
department of Moody College
of Communication at the
University of Texas.
Dr. Fuller-Seeley's research
focuses on American film, radio,
and television history and
audience reception studies.
I could tell you about all of
her wonderful Hollywood books,
but I'm just too excited
because her new book, Jack Benny
and the Golden Age of Radio
Comedy, came out just last week,
published by University of
California Press, very exciting,
and Dr. Fuller-Seeley has
received a National Endowment
for the Humanities fellowship
for university teachers
to support the project.
Dr. Fuller-Seeley has
published numerous articles
and book chapters on early TV
and Hollywood film audiences
and performers and she's served
as a historical consultant
for PBS.
Okay, Alex, Dr. Alex
Kupfer -- Kupfer?
Sorry.
>> Dr. Alex Kupfer: Kupfer.
>> -- Kupfer is currently
visiting assistant professor
in the film department
at Vassar College.
He received his PhD from the
Department of Cinema Studies
at New York University's Tisch
School of the Arts and his MA
in Cinema and Media
Studies from UCLA.
His current book project
chronicles the relationship
among collegiate
football, the American film
and radio industries, and
higher education before 1960.
Okay, then Mary Ann Watson,
Dr. Mary -- I'm sorry --
Dr. Mary Ann Watson is the
author of The Expanding Vista:
American Television
in The Kennedy Years
and Defining Visions: Television
and The American Experience
in the 20th Century.
Dr. Watson has contributed
book chapters
to many works including
the Columbia History
of American Television
and she is the coeditor,
and for today this is
really the important one,
she's the coeditor of Norman
Corwin's One World Flight:
The Lost Journal of
Radio's Greatest Writer,
who she interviewed, right?
Before he died, which is
a great connection there.
Dr. Watson has received
research awards
from the Rockefeller Foundation
and National Endowment
for the Humanities and
she's served as a consultant
to several documentaries
including Color Adjustment:
Blacks in Prime Time, Making
Sense of the Sixties, JFK,
and JFK Breaking the
News, all of which aired
on American Public Television.
Okay, next is Cynthia Meyers
and Dr. Cynthia B. Meyers
is an associate professor
of communication at Mt. St.
Vincent College in New York
and the author of A Word from
Our Sponsor: Admen, Advertising,
and The Golden Age of Radio
which received the Broadcast
Historian Prize from the Library
of American Broadcasting
Foundation in 2016.
She's written numerous articles
and book chapters on the history
and culture of the American
Advertising industry
and its often overlooked
role in the production
of commercial broadcast
programming.
And, then, Ross Melnick.
Dr. Ross Melnick
specializes in media,
industry history
analysis, and is the author
of American Showman: Samuel
"Roxy" Rothafel and the Birth
of the Entertainment
Industry, 1908-1935,
published by Columbia
University Press.
His research has been
published in numerous journals,
including Cinema Journal,
Film History, Moving Image,
Historical Journal of
Film and Television --
Film, Radio, and Television.
How could I leave that out?
He was named an Academy film
scholar in 2017 by the Academy
of Motion Picture
Arts and Sciences
and awarded a National Endowment
for the Humanities fellowship
in 2015-2016, and was
a postdoctoral fellow
at Fox Center for Humanistic
Inquiry at Emory University.
Prior to completing his
doctorate, he served as curator
of the collection at the
Museum of the Moving Image.
He's been an archivist
and, very interestingly,
he's worked in film marketing
in the commercial industry
for Miramax, MGM,
and DreamWorks.
Okay, our commercial
respondents.
First is, not to put you in --
>> Ross Melnick: I've
never been described
as a commercial respondent.
>> Michael Socolow:
Michael Freedman.
In a distinguished career
spanning more than 35 years,
Michael Freedman has
served as general manager
of CBS Radio Network
News, managing editor
for the Broadcast Division of
United Press International,
a senior vice-president
of the University
of Maryland University College,
Leadership press secretary
for the majority whip of the
US House of Representatives,
vice-president of communications
for George Washington
University, GW Professor
of Journalism, and
executive director
of the University's
Global Media and Institute,
where he's produced the Public
Broadcasting series The Kalb
Report and the weekly network
radio programs, This Just In
and GW Presents American Jazz.
Over the course of his
career, Freedman's collaborated
on programming such icons as
Walter Cronkite, Marvin Kalb,
Tony Bennett, Ernie
Harwell, Robert Trout,
Richard C. Hottelet, Dan
Rather, and Charles Osgood.
Freedman is co-author of The
Broadcast Voice Handbook,
and a contributing author to
Broadcasting Through Crisis,
Responsible Journalism, and
The Encyclopedia of Journalism.
He's a member of The National
Press Club Board of Governors
and The Museum Educator
Advisory team, and has served
on the advisory boards of
the Duke Ellington School
of the Arts, The RTDNA, and
The Radio History Society.
Sam Litzinger.
>> Sam Litzinger: That's me.
>> Michael Socolow: Sam is --
I hear Sam every weekend on
620 AM, WZON in Bangor, Maine.
Stephen King's station, so.
This is quite a --
everybody in Bangor knows Sam.
Sam Litzinger joined CBS New
in September 1998 serving
as both anchor and
reporter for CBS Radio News.
Before CBS, Litzinger helped
create The World Radio Public
Radio Network based in
Kentucky and he's worked
for mutual NBC Radio, CNN,
and The Associated
Press Radio Network,
as well as several commercial
and public radio operations
throughout the United States.
Litzinger has reported from
England, France, Spain, Poland,
Germany, Israel, two miles
inside of Mammoth Cave,
and from a ship in the middle
of a North Atlantic storm.
Among his notable interviews are
the Dalai Lama, Scotty Moore,
Lemmy from the heavy metal
band Motorhead, Richard Nixon,
that's an interesting
[laughter], Tony Bennett,
Maya Angelou, and the
Florida man who specializes
in capturing alligators
that wander
into people's swimming pools.
Litzinger was born in
Titusville, Pennsylvania,
where he began his
broadcasting career at 16
and he has a master's degree
in comparative philosophy
from the University of Hawaii.
And, then, Shawn VanCour.
Shawn is an assistant professor
of media archival studies
at UCLA's department
of information studies.
His scholarship focuses on
the history and preservation
of early radio and
television programming
in the United States.
His book, Making Radio: Early
Radio Production and the Rise
of Modern Sound Culture,
forthcoming from
Oxford University Press,
traces the development of
dominant production practices
and performance styles for
early US radio and their impact
on adjacent fields of
film and music recording.
Okay. So, to end
the introduction,
I asked the members of the panel
just to do very basic things.
The first, I asked
the scholars to speak
about their interactions
with commercial broadcasting
community as scholars,
researchers, and educators,
and I asked our commercial
broadcasting representatives
to reflect a bit on how
historical audio is used
and preserved in the industry.
And, the goal of this panel
is actually discussion.
We also want to hear from you.
We want to think
about how scholars
and researchers can work
with commercial broadcasters
for educational and
research purposes.
So, Noah, take it away.
>> Noah Arceneaux:
Good afternoon.
I felt a little strange
when I realized
that I was slotted
on this panel.
My dissertation completed,
now, 10 years ago,
it was about the origins
of commercial broadcasting,
which is why Josh probably
threw me in this slot,
but after I completed
my dissertation,
I started to do research on even
earlier era; the pre-radio era
of wireless telegraphy.
As Michael mentioned,
I wrote something.
Wanamaker's Department Store
had wireless telegraph in 1911,
the New York Herald was
transmitting news via Morse code
even earlier than that.
We don't have recordings of
these things and the fact --
it's just never really crossed
my mind would there even
be recordings?
Who would record Morse
code transmission?
I only know of one such
recording from that era.
What I wanted to share with
you, and I'm just going
to take full advantage of this
opportunity because I'm on stage
and I have a projector
so I'm going
to take full advantage
of this opportunity.
Because of my research
into wireless telegraphy,
I spent the summer in Oxford;
the Marconi archives are
at the library there.
The Bodleian Library.
I was told on my first
day it's not 'Bowedlean',
and you sound like
a dumb American.
The 'Bodleian'.
So, I spent two months there
digging through the archives,
photographing as much as I
could and I found this document.
This is what I wanted
to share with you.
And I was aware, of course,
of the Radio Preservation
Task Force
and I thought this is a
really weird artifact.
This is a radio recording?
Maybe? It's a composition
book from 1897.
Okay? Marconi had one of his
employees go out on the ocean
in a harbor and was
sending signals back
to a station located
on the Isle of Wight.
And they recorded the
transmissions on little strips
of paper and I found many
of these strips of paper.
But for some reason they pasted
these into a child's notebook,
which has an essay
about Celtic Britain.
So, of course, I find
myself reading the essay
and admiring this
child's penmanship,
which is much better than mine.
Yeah. 1897, that's a 7, not a 4.
So, I was, okay, Marconi
-- he's doing wireless,
which will eventually
become radio.
He wants to make money.
I'll just scroll through.
That's a commercial service.
Is this recording
of commercial radio?
Maybe. I don't know.
Depends on how you
define radio, right?
Now what is the academic
significance of this?
I have no idea.
What's the theoretical
implication of this?
I don't know.
I just thought this was
really weird and cool
and I wanted to share it.
Right? So, that's
what I'm doing.
I thought maybe I could turn
these strips of paper back
into Morse code and make my
students build a radio receiver.
Would there be some
academic value of that?
I'm not sure.
But, in terms of
my dissertation,
which was about 1920s radio,
my argument, in a nutshell,
was that there was
advertising on American radio
from the very beginning.
And this is not commonly
acknowledged
because we don't have
recordings from 1920 and 1921.
A station owned by AT&T, WEAF,
airs the first radio commercial.
This is in all the
textbooks that we use.
This is memorialized
as a significant first.
I was looking at
department stores
that had their own
radio stations
and I'm just convinced --
common sense tells me
the department stores
were advertising.
In the program listings that
were listed in the newspapers,
they had programs about shoes,
programs about women's coats.
Surely they were doing
ads for those products.
And some of the listings in
the newspapers would even say,
"Music brought to you
by Victor Records".
Well, if they're putting
it in newspaper listing,
surely they must have been
saying it on the air as well,
but because we don't
have a recording of it,
WEAF and AT&T get the credit.
The one book on the
commercialization of radio
by Susan Smulyan, I
don't think she's here.
Is that correct?
Really privileges the networks
because those are the records
that we have and I believe
that there was really just some
explicit commercialism going on.
And the reason I think this
era is important is this is
when everything was really
formed and established,
the network system, the
commercial broadcasting system,
the rules that we still are
following to some degree today.
So I think it would be good
if we could understand the
origins a little better.
But obviously -- there are
some recordings from 1920s.
I won't say there are none.
I talked with Chuck
Howell and Mike Henry
when I was doing my
dissertation research.
From being at this conference,
I've learned there are
maybe some more recordings
from that era that
have been uncovered
but we don't have anything like
a thorough, complete coverage.
But obviously commercial radio
is a dominant form of radio.
I don't mean to malign
public radio
but that's what many
people listen to.
And there'd just be
such tremendous value
if we had more of it.
And I'm not talking
about program logs
or what music was
played on what station.
We can uncover the music,
but it's the advertising
that we want.
It's the local announcers.
It's that regional feel.
And this lack of recordings --
it's not that the problem
has gone away as we all know.
In 2011, there was a
massive power outage
in southern California.
It was really remarkable.
Basically, Los Angeles
down to the border.
It was like all of southern
California lost power.
San Diego people went berserk.
Like it was the zombie
apocalypse coming.
Your ATM wouldn't work because
there was no electricity,
so the ATMs wouldn't work.
Cell phones were dying.
There was only one radio station
in San Diego that managed
to stay on the air
for the duration.
The power was back
on by midnight.
It only lasted a half a day.
But only one radio
station, KPBS,
our local PBS station
went off the air.
One local news station,
an AM station,
managed to stay on the air.
And I have a representative
from Nielson come to my classes
and talk and he shared
with me the ratings data
from that particular day.
As you can imagine, there
was this unbelievable spike
at four o'clock in
the afternoon,
every single radio
tuned to that station
because it was the only
thing that was going on.
And when I called
them, they don't --
I mean they have a
record of what happened
but there's no actual recording.
I don't think it even
crossed anyone's mind, hey,
this is an historic moment.
So, maybe that gives people
some things to think about
and respond to, but I wanted
to share this with you.
Thank you for indulging me.
>> Heather Birks: Am I next?
Okay. Hi. Heather Birks,
as Michael introduced me,
executive director of the
Broadcast Education Association.
And I just have to
say, I'm sitting kind
of with some VA royalty here.
Right? Got some dissertation
award winners.
We have a book winner.
So, that's kind of
exciting for me.
So I feel very fortunate to
be in your company today.
I'm going to keep my
remarks very brief.
I'm not sure how many
of you are familiar
with Broadcast Education
Association.
We're an academic
media organization.
Our members are traditional
researchers
but also creative scholars,
which makes being in a place
like this important for us
because while our members are
using traditional research
methods, the creative folks
are also creating content,
in particular, with archives
that I'll just talk
about for a minute.
And some of our relationships
that we have and the importance,
obviously, of students
and faculty having access
to those archives to be
able to create projects
for themselves whether
it's an audio documentary,
which we awarded our
festival of media arts
if anyone's curious about that.
And, also, with the Library of
American Broadcasting Foundation
and the archives,
trying to make sure
that all our student members
and faculty members are aware
of what they have and I know
that they've got symposiums
and that we're trying to
figure out how we can partner
with them just to give
access to everybody.
And that's pretty much it.
But if people have
questions after --
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah, well, we've got several --
actually we've got several
projects that we, history,
specifically broadcast media
history projects that we do.
One is the Library of American
Broadcast award that alternates.
One year it's a book award,
which will be awarded
this coming year in 2018.
And then the alternating
years, it's a creative award.
So, if you've done
a documentary,
if you've done some kind
of interactive multimedia
project, we'll award that.
Last year, in fact,
it was audio.
A guy named Terry Likes
out of Tennessee State
University had produced a series
of mini documentaries
that he aired
on the local PBS radio station
or public station in Tennessee.
So, $5000 prize, which
is a pretty good award.
And then this year, for the
first time, we are given a grant
by Richard Liebner
and Carol Cooper.
They were the founders of
-- I'm spacing the name --
of the talent agency
because it was UTA.
[Inaudible].
Ah, Beanstalk.
They did Beanstalk, which is
now part of United Talent.
And the endowment is for --
it's a grant for a research
in progress for proposal
and progress creative work
that relates somehow to media
and broadcast history.
Cynthia and I were
talking a little bit
at lunchtime about this.
Some of our board members,
you know what I mean,
obviously history is
-- they are worried
that it would be too
limiting, media history.
But I'm convincing
them that that is --
I mean, that opens the doors to
all kinds of things, in fact,
it's huge that we're
all this gigantic.
So, the deadline for the
submissions for that,
I think it's December
or January.
And we'll be giving that
out annually, $2500 grant.
And more things to come too.
I mean, again, we've got a good
relationship with the Library
of American Broadcasting
Foundation
and we feel very happy that
they've kind of found a home
with BEA knowing that there are
so many talented
scholars out there.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Kathy Fuller-Seeley:
Gosh, since this just came
out last week -- I
don't have that much
to say other than hooray.
It was about a 12-year project.
Took me about three
years to write it.
It's not the only fantastic book
out about Omega Radio performer.
Also, check out David
Weinstein's new book,
The Eddie Cantor Story.
We're going to be like
twins here about this.
But if I can tell one very
quick story about the importance
of Jack Benny's show to
commercial radio, at large,
in the business and
consumer economy,
is quickly the story of Jell-O.
I can't resist telling the story
of Jell-O in one minute or less.
Jell-O in the spring and fall
of 1934 was a dying product.
It was 40 years old.
It's competition, even A&P
Jell-O, cost half the price
and tasted twice as good.
So, General Foods was
about to sink the product
and put it out of business.
But, indeed an advertising
agency Young and Rubicam
and I learned so much
about the importance
of advertising agencies as
creative and business forces.
For instance, Cynthia Meyers.
Advertising agency Young and
Rubicam came to General Foods
in the Jell-O division
and they said,
"You've got one last shot."
They said, "You have your
chemist fix the taste,
you have your marketers
cut your price in half.
We'll pick up some talent and
we'll give it one last shot."
Because back in the day,
if a radio audience
enjoyed the programming,
they were being trained to go
out and purchase the product.
So they said, "One shot."
Jack Benny was not
their first choice.
He was about their
fourth choice.
He had been fired by his
previous three sponsors
because he was determined
to be his own show runner.
He wouldn't let them tell
why kind of comedy to do,
what kind of programming to do.
So, he's kind of a retread.
But Young and Rubicam said,
"Let's give it a shot.
He was really funny with
the advertisements."
So they bring Benny and
Mary Livingstone on board.
They start the Jell-O
program in October 1934.
And in the first two months,
the comedy was really great
but no Jell-O is selling.
Even though the price
has been cut.
And, General Foods is going,
"Well, everybody now has
to work at half price.
We're going to cut
the salaries."
And Jack Benny and Mary
Livingstone say, "Okay.
We'll work without salary
for the next 10 weeks.
Give us that long to try and
get sales of a product boosted
and then we'll call it quits."
So, for 10 weeks they worked
without salary so that the rest
of the cast could
still earn a living.
And they sell the
heck out of Jell-O.
Don Wilson wears a striped tie
in the lemon, lime, cherry,
and orange striped variety.
They do skits.
Talk about Romeo
and Jell-O-ette.
They are on the Good
Ship Jell-O.
They're just Jell-O-ing every
six ways you could think of it.
And about eight weeks later,
sales start to skyrocket.
Pretty soon, they are
selling more Jell-O
than can actually be
made at the factory.
They're in a small town
in upstate New York.
They end up having to buy
other products and rebrand them
as Jell-O just to have enough
for Jack Benny to sell.
By Christmastime, early January,
General Foods was so happy
at this complete
business turn-around,
here's the selling power of
radio, of commercial radio,
they had a party at Jack
and Mary's apartment.
They provided one of
those big lottery checks
for all of their back salary.
They said you've
saved our product.
Hooray. Just wait until
we get Bill Cosby.
No. I kid you.
They weren't that prescient.
So, literally, a radio comedy
program turned the fortunes
of a consumer product and the
only joke Mary Livingstone had
to say about it was that the
company had provided a great big
tray of shimmering red
Jell-O and she told the maid,
"Get that crap outta here."
Which she was a little
sorry got overheard.
But, working on Benny
was a wonderful project
because I thought of him --
I wanted to tell the story
of the radio show instead
of the story of his
private life.
And I found he was a
tremendous show runner,
advertising creator, and
executive and intermedia star,
and an incredible
maestro and director
of the timing of
his [inaudible].
Please. Enjoy my book.
It's half price on
Kindle [inaudible].
[ Laughter and Applause ]
>> Alex Kupfer: Sure.
I want to talk just for a
few minutes about one example
of where some of my research
in radio has taken me as a way
to sort of offer some of
these questions about access
and preservation of
materials and then how
that shapes scholarship
potentially.
And, the example that I want
to discuss actually came
out of the first
RPTF conference.
And it was some research
that I had started to do
on a show called The Land
Grant College Radio Hour,
which aired in the 1930s
on NBC Blue Affiliates.
So, just very briefly, this
was a monthly show that came
out of the National Farm
and Home Hour series.
And during The Land Grant
the first few years,
it would feature three
talks on domestic topics,
or agricultural topics,
delivered by speakers
supplied either
by a rotating university
extension program
or the US Department
of Agriculture.
By the 1930s, interest had
really waned in the show
and it was rehauled as kind
of this traveling
road show program.
Once a month, it
would be broadcast
from a different land
grant college radio station
from throughout the country.
So, this was a really
interesting production process
because even at schools
which had their own stations,
it was fairly collaborative
between NBC
and faculty and students.
So, NBC for instance, offered
technical support, equipment,
and some of the music you used
in the show as well as sort
of legal support over getting
the rights to this music,
while faculty and students
kind of did the rest,
including perform
the entire show.
So, the lectures that
were initially part
of the show were replaced by
kind of more general promotion
of each school's service to
the state and sort of histories
about the state and
the university.
So, there were things like
historical reenactments
and interviews and various
musical performances
by different campus groups.
Between 1936 and
1940, it was produced
at 47 different land grant
colleges in 44 different states,
ranging from Hawaii to Maine.
So, I think the Land Grant
College Radio Hour raises a lot
of sort of interesting
issues related
to access and preservation.
So, because of this
decentralized collaborative
model between NBC and
the different schools,
there is no single,
real, archival home
for documents related
to the program.
So, in practical terms too,
this also means very few
[inaudible] episodes.
I found four episodes going
literally episode by episode
and contacting different
archives and universities.
Records can be very
difficult to find.
So, for instance, records
documenting the development
of the show were housed at the
University of Wisconsin-Madison
in the Wisconsin
Historical Society.
And actually to fly to
the University of Nevada
to listen to their recordings.
They were one of the few
who had transcription discs.
And luckily they were
nice enough to transfer it
to a record where I could
later play it for my students.
And they had also the files
related to the production
of the show as well as things
like letters from alumni
from across the country
who are really interested
in hearing their school
being discussed on the air.
So, dealing with multiple
archives is not exceptional.
I'm sure all the people
here could really talk
about the dozens
potentially archives
that they worked
on over the years.
But I think it does pose a
challenge for how scholars
and archivists can address
situations like this show
where to discuss it, you
realistically would have to go
to numerous archives,
potentially up to four dozen,
to find where the
show was recorded.
And this is because
it's an example
where you have this commercial
material from the networks
which had been mixed into
institutional collections.
So, it's not housed in
NBC records but in each
of these different
university archives.
So, I'll just sort of stop here
just by posing this question.
Again, how can we formulate
ways to find this material
to make it accessible and then
ultimately to preserve it?
Thank you.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Mary Ann Watson: I just
wanted to say a few words
about the great privilege of
my life, which was working
with Norman Corwin editing a
book on his one-world flight.
Working with Norman
was quite remarkable
because he had the most
fastidious files I've ever seen
but it was all Norman's doing.
He tells the story
of when he left --
shortly after he left CBS, he
ran into a secretary from CBS
on the street in New York,
and she said to him, "Norman,
they're about to throw out
all these transcription discs
of your programs.
Would you like them?"
He was crestfallen that
this body of work that was
so joyously saluted was going
to be just unceremoniously
tossed out.
But he kept fastidious records
and when we sat down to talk
about One World Flight
that, of course,
was probably the reason he ended
up leaving commercial radio was
because his conclusion
at the end
of that documentary
series was that democracy
and representative
democracy and socialism,
the best of socialism, might
actually work together.
And that we should
consider that.
Of course, in 1947, that
was not at all something
that could be abided in
commercial broadcasting
and he left CBS after that.
But when I sat down with him
to talk about One World Flight,
of course, we had
the programs and --
but I asked him did
he have letters,
did he have things he might
have kept and he said, "Oh,
I kept a handwritten journal."
And he said to his assistant,
"Do you know where
that might be?"
And he said, "Yeah, I saved it
from a black trash bag that was
about to be thrown out."
And, so, that journal
exists and the book could be
in Norman's voice
because of that.
And, just a few other things.
Lately, I've been doing a lot
of consulting for documentaries
and programs where people are
looking for commercial things.
For instance, CNN is now
doing a documentary based
on David Maraniss'
wonderful book about the city
of Detroit, Once
In a Great City.
And I've been trying to help
them find very, you would think,
easy things to find, like
things about the Motown Review,
radio coverage of the Motown
Review in 1962, radio coverage
of the introduction
of the Ford Mustang,
things that you think
this is a no-brainer.
We'll find this easily.
No can do.
It's just - it's very
difficult to find that stuff.
It's the same story that
you've all experienced.
So, thanks.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Cynthia Meyers:
Is this working?
Hi, I'm Cynthia Meyers
and I wrote a book called
A Word From Our Sponsor.
I just want to make
one or two points
about doing historical
work in media industries.
First of all, Heather and I were
talking over lunch about some
of the challenges when
we're also dealing
with commercial entities
and companies
that might have records
or recordings
or archives or materials.
Getting access to them is very
difficult, and for many, many,
many reasons, and I know
that we've had conversations
here this week
about some of those reasons.
But, one of the things
I was talking to Heather
about was the fact that
history, for a lot of people
in the media industry
is something
to be embarrassed about.
It's not something
necessarily to be proud of.
Because those old shows
are kind of funny.
You know, they're sort of weird.
And, they're old fashioned.
And connecting the current
today, forward thinking company
with these sort of
old-fashioned artifacts
or these old fashioned ideas
or these old-fashioned forms
of culture is not always
something that they want to do.
And so some of the issues, and I
hope we can talk about it today,
about private entities,
how they save,
or don't save, their materials.
I think we need to remember
those of us, the archivists
and the scholars, that it's
not just a financial issue
or storage issue, it's also
there's a cultural sort
of attitude issue and as
educators, we really need
to reach out and try to
figure out how to make some
of those companies feel that
their history is valuable rather
than something to be
embarrassed about.
The other point I was going to
make was just that we all know
about the [inaudible] of
media and especially radio.
We talked about how
there's very little of it
that has actually
been preserved.
Well, this is also
true of advertising.
Print advertising in magazines
is pretty well preserved
because there are lots and
lots and lots and lots and lots
of copies of magazines.
So, a lot of advertising
history really is based
on magazine advertising because
you can actually access it,
which is great.
So, when I try to write
about radio and the role
of advertising agencies in
radio, naturally, there are not
that many recordings
or that many records
because it's ephemeral
and it's a media industry.
But, what also happened with
some radio recordings is
that the advertising elements
in the recordings are
sometimes cut out.
So, there are all sorts of
recordings circulating out there
like in the OTR community in
which that Lipton Tea commercial
in the inner sanctum
just doesn't appear.
As a scholar, of course, I
want that context and I want
to be able to understand
how those things sounded
in those media artifacts.
So, I'm just going
to put it out there
that not only are the radio
programs ephemeral and difficult
to preserve and capture, but
then the role of the ad industry
and the importance
of the advertising texts
themselves were not seen
as important by some people who
are preserving these things.
And as we're looking forward
as archivists and scholars,
what are the things today
that we're not thinking
are important now
but may be important
in the future.
That is something that I
think we need to keep in mind.
>> Ross Melnick: Okay
I guess I'm last.
Let me see if I can tell you two
very short interlinked history
which will hopefully
be very short
and then we'll have
a relationship
to the conversation
we're having.
I wrote this book,
American Showman, on Roxy
and it's interesting because
if you'll go back to 1925,
that's also somewhat of the
origin of the amateur hour,
in part because of course Samuel
Roxy Roth leaves the Capital
Theater to eventually open the
Roxy in 1927 and when he does
that Major Bo's takes over the
radio show and when he does
that Major Bo's is actually
a real estate developer
who becomes, a movie mogul, a
movie theater mogul if you will.
And then he takes over the
radio show and runs that show
from '25-'34, when at WHN,
by the way Roxy begins
at WAF, it's call back.
When he begins that show
at WHN he actually brings
that show to NBC in 1935.
So for my purposes I
have that problem twice.
And not even related necessarily
to his show and then he goes
to CBS for a year which
means no luck finding that.
Once again, same issue, so here
I'm working on two broadcasters
over a 20 year period.
I think the Library of
Congress has something close
to like 20 recordings or 40
recordings of the amateur hour.
And the amateur hour as you
know goes form 1934-1970.
From Dumont, there's my
call back over there.
>> Michael Freedman:
Thank you, Michael,
what a great panel
you've put together.
This is terrific, I'm absorbing
everything and it's bringing
so many things to mind.
I will share some
experiences in attempting
to save audio archives.
I'll synopsize these for you.
I ran UPI's radio
network in the 1980s
and was the general
manager of CBS radio network
in the '90s through into 2000.
And I think, as Mary Ann
said, there's a long tradition
of unceremoniously tossing
out archival material in radio
and it has long been
up to enterprising
in committed executives who have
the power to make that happen
and committed, thoughtful talent
like Sam Litzinger to bring
that material back to life
and then help preserve it.
At UPI, where I ran
the broadcast division
from 1986-1990, it included
over sighted UPI radio network,
which was then the principal
competitor to the AP radio
for audio services, and at
peak UPI radio I had more
than 800 subscriber
stations around the country
and was the principal
supplier of news audio
to NPR for many years.
A lot of people thought that our
UPI correspondents were actually
NPR, like Bill Small with the
White House and Pye Chamberlayne
and Bonnie Erbe at Capitol
Hill, Bob Fosse in Los Angeles,
Carol Brooks in London,
Rob Navies is
at the Kennedy Space Center,
a lot of people thought
they were NPR people,
they were UPI radio folks.
One day in 1986 I received a
call from our chief engineer
who lived in Pekin, Illinois,
and he said that if we
didn't get these boxes
out of his basement by the end
of the week his wife
had instructed him
to put them out for trash.
So we're hearing repetitive
narrations like these.
Well, it turned out to be the
UPI radio archive dating back
to 1958 and so we hired a mover
and we brought everything
to Washington.
And there was the mother lode,
the archive of the United Press
International's audio services.
And it included Yearend review
programs dating back to 1958,
newsfeed material, which is of
questionable long term interest,
but, a lot of voices and
a lot of news coverage
that hadn't been heard
in a very long time.
We began to catalogue them;
we built a room to house them.
Sometime after I left UPI
another executive determined
that the boxes were clutter
and ordered them removed
and that was the last
anyone ever saw of them.
So they were found, retrieved,
saved, and then removed
and to this day nobody
knows where they went.
In 1988 we created what was
called a UPI Radio Thirty Year
Retrospective, which
was a giveaway item
at the Radio Television News
Directors Association Convention
in Las Vegas and
that contained a lot
of wonderful historical
audio from the archive
and that is what remains of the
archive, that little compilation
and so we're happy
we saved that,
we're happy we put it together.
I'm going to spin past CBS for
a moment and come up to the time
when I joined George
Washington University after CBS
and I received a call from a
wonderful, long time friend,
Bart Tessler, who's the
head of news programming
at Westwood One, who said
the network was moving
out of its headquarters
in Crystal City, Virginia,
which is Arlington, Virginia,
and his bosses had instructed
him to either find a home
for the Mutual Broadcasting
System and NBC Radio archive
or everything was going in the
dumpster at the end of the week.
So we hired the same movers and
the collection was picked up;
900 boxes of seven and 10 inch
reels of tape and cassette tapes
and we brought them to George
Washington University here
in Washington.
The collection included all
of Larry King's radio
programs on Mutual.
I pulled one out of
the box and put it
on a reel-to-reel tape recorder
and it was Larry King
interviewing Buster Crab,
so you never knew what
you were going to hear
when you pulled tapes
out of there.
Several dramatic and
science fiction radio series
that were initiated in the
1970s including the Mutual Radio
Theater and a lot of newsfeed
material including their yearend
review programs.
Those 900 boxes were then sent
to the Washington Research
Library Consortium Warehouse
in Upper Marlborough, Maryland,
and were placed in
that facility.
Mutual did have an archivist
who helped catalogue those
and GW invested some
time and some money
into cataloguing that.
We tried to raise
money to digitize them,
by this time the processes
were in place to digitize them.
It was expensive and we were
not able to raise the money.
Not from the owners
of Westwood One,
not from Larry King,
not from anybody.
It was very difficult, in fact,
in turned out to be impossible
to raise the money at that
time for the digitization.
I'm pleased to tell you that
those 900 boxes are still
in climate-controlled storage,
although, as you can imagine,
the tape is undoubtedly
deteriorating.
It was moved to another
warehouse location
in Pennsylvania some
years ago, but it is still
under the auspices of
the Gillman Library
at George Washington University.
At CBS, Sam and I had the
great pleasure of collaborating
on a number of documentaries
and wonderful archival programs.
I served as executive producer
for several historical programs
at the turn of the millennium,
including the three hour CBS
News 20th Century Roundup,
which included the final reunion
of all of the surviving members
of Ed Murrow's original
team from World War II.
We had Richard C. Hotilett and
Howard K. Smith and Larry LeSeur
as well as Bob Trout and Norman
Corwin joined us for the program
from California and we
used historical audio
from the CBS archive in the
broadcast which ran at the end
of 1999 on many of the then
400 CBS radio affiliates
around the country.
I saved the three ten inch
master reels of the program
and created CDs of the masters
so the programming
would not be lost
and I think I may
be the only person
that has those at this point.
Walter Cronkite and I
collaborated on several series
at CBS including a millennial
series called Walter Cronkite's
Post Script to the 20th Century.
These are 31 one minute capsules
in which Walter Cronkite
reviews historical events
of the 20th Century
using archival audio
and then offers a
postscript on the aftermath
and the significance
of each episode.
We created CDs of the set
and I don't believe CBS
has that in its archive.
So, I think Sam has a
set and I have a set
and I think that's the archive.
Walter Cronkite's
final special report
for CBS news was a radio report
when John Glenn went
back into space.
In November, November 4,
1998, Walter and I went
to Houston together and during
the 40th anniversary of NASA,
before 2000 people,
Walter Cronkite engaged
in fifteen minute live
special report for radio,
A Conversation with
the Astronauts.
Fortunately, C-SPAN was
there and C-SPAN recorded it
and at the end of that
broadcast Walter Cronkite closed
by saying, "And that's the
way it is, November 4th 1998,
this is Walter Cronkite
for CBS News in Houston."
That was the last time Walter
Cronkite offered his signature
close on a CBS broadcast.
It is preserved because
C-SPAN was there
and it is now available
through the C-SPAN archive,
the video and the audio.
There are, what I
would refer to,
as the Latter-Day
Saints in audio archives.
Sam and I collaborated on a
one hour centennial tribute
to Louis Armstrong, which
featured Tony Bennett,
Charles Osgood, and others
who studio Centennial Salute
to Duke Ellington and perhaps
the last radio interview
with the great big band leader,
Artie Shaw, on his
90th birthday.
It's a memorable interview that
Sam conducted with Artie Shaw,
and interviews with Les
Paul, B.B. King, and others
and I do not believe that
these were retained by CBS.
I was in my storage facility
in my couple of days ago,
I have the masters
to all of those
on ten inch reel-to-reel tape.
And we did make CDs
of some of those.
So, gives you an idea of how
tough it is to engage in this.
I don't know, you know,
what has transpired
in the last few years at CBS.
There was a wonderful
man named Tom Garofalo,
who was the CBS audio archivist
and if you can imagine Mel
Blanc's character protecting
Jack Benny's vault that's the
way I thought of Tom Garofalo
and I do recall asking him
for some archival material
and Tom brought up to my office
the original transcription disc
of Major Bo's Original Amateur
Hour with the whole Vulcan Four
and Frank Sinatra and the
original transcription disc
of War of the Worlds and,
so, I know they were there
at that time and then
they were taken back
down to Tom Garofalo's vault.
And, but, this is a -- it's a
fascinating day and this is all
to say that I salute everybody
who is working toward the
preservation of these materials.
I do think that there are some
important questions to ask
and maybe we'll get into
them including, you know,
who do you work with
at these networks?
Sam and I have some
thoughts about that.
And also, what needs
to be saved?
Because the archives, there are
vast materials that are still
out there in different places.
There are matters of space,
there are matters of time,
there are matters of money.
Because the networks want
to monetize all this
stuff if they can.
If they're still holding onto
it, and they're very reluctant
to release it for
other purposes.
So, thank you very much.
>> Sam Litzinger: Hi,
I'm Sam Litzinger.
I'll be brief because I really
want to hear from you more
than I want to hear
from me, but following
up on what Mike was saying.
Some people have the idea that
CBS has this vast audio archive
that I secretly go into
like in the early, you know,
Get Smart days of television
when people go through doors
and -- I don't know where
it is, if it exists.
There is an archive across
the street from West 57th,
the main broadcasting facility,
primarily aimed at
television now.
The audio stuff sort
of floats around,
but I don't know where it is.
I've used, I think,
exactly one batch since 1998
and that was Tom Garofalo,
we were doing a Duke Ellington
special, and I said to Tom,
"Do you have anything on Duke
Ellington that I can use?"
and he said, "I don't know," and
kind of slunk off for three days
and then he came
back with this box.
And the box was a big box
and it just said things
like, "Ellington."
So I started listening
to a reel-to-reel tape
and what I found, for example,
was a Mike Wallace interview
with Duke Ellington sitting
at the piano for an hour
and apparently it never aired.
They just decided it
wasn't worth airing.
So that's sort of sitting there.
So there isn't really, at CBS,
an audio archives that I use
at all on a regular basis.
I think Mike and I
have been to that,
kind of by default being
part of the CBS archives.
I thought I would play you
something if that's alright.
So you can actually hear
what I occasionally do
with the archival material that
we have or that I can find.
A while back they came to me
about a week before
the 75th anniversary
of the CBS World News
Roundup and they said,
"Can you do a special
show on that for the," --
I think it was going to
be for the weekend roundup
that we do -- and I said,
"Okay," because I say
that when I don't
know what else to say.
And so I got to digging around
in our archives and I tried
to figure something out,
and then, what I normally do
when I'm processing it is find
out what material I have at hand
and then I write
around it and then try
to make something out of it.
So if you don't mind, can
you play that for us please?
I think it's seven minutes,
something like that.
>> Recording: This
is Sam Litzinger.
In March of 1938, Europe
was getting ready for war.
Adolf Hitler's German
troops were cheered
as they marched into Austria.
A union, Hitler called
it, the [inaudible].
It was a blatant annexation
in the eyes of many others
and another indication that the
Nazis wanted more than the rest
of the world was
willing to give them.
[ Foreign Language ]
On March 13th, CBS
radio executives decided
to put together a news program
to tell Americans
what was going on.
>> Robert Trout: The program
of St. Louis Blues
originally scheduled
for this time has
been cancelled.
>> Sam Litzinger: Robert Trout
anchored the first CBS World
News Roundup with sometimes
shaky audio links to people
like Edward R. Murrow in Paris,
in London, Vienna, in Berlin.
>> Robert Trout: To bring you
the picture of Europe tonight,
Columbia now presents
a special broadcast
which will include pickups
direct from London, from Paris,
and such European capitals,
as at this late hour abroad,
have communication
channels available.
This is Bob Trout speaking
to you from New York,
opening Columbia's short
wave transatlantic program
to cover the key
cities of Europe.
But before switching to
our first European capital,
let us look once again at
the latest news bulletins
with swift, fresh details
of a Europe in turmoil.
>> Sam Litzinger: CBS management
insisted on live reports then,
recorded pieces were
considered suspect somehow,
and the technology for reporting
from the field was cumbersome
and unreliable anyway, so
live reports were the norm.
>> Robert Trout: And now
Columbia begins its radio tour
of Europe's capital cities
with a transoceanic pickup
from London where we are to
hear Ellen C. Roarkinson,
woman labor member of
the House of Commons.
We take you now to
London England.
>> Sam Litzinger: They called
them pickups back then,
we call them live
shots or hits today.
I must say they're a heck
of a lot easier to do now
than they were back in 1938
when there was no
internet, no cell phones.
>> Roarkinson: While
Hitler continued or,
you might say completed,
his triumphant conquest
of Austria today, Great Britain
remained relatively calm.
Here in London there were some
anti-German demonstrations this
afternoon, a few
clashes with the police,
but nothing at all serious
compared with what I saw
in Vienna Friday and yesterday.
What happened was this;
the International Peace
Campaign organized a big meeting
in Trafalgar Square.
>> Litzinger: CBS's William L.
Shirer had just come to London
from Vienna and so was
able to tell what was going
on in both the cities.
>> Shirer: -- in the
British government.
There were boos and hisses
at the mention of the name
of the Prime Minister.
When the meeting broke up,
most of the crowd
numbering several thousand,
and giving the clenched
fists moods,
marched on the German Embassy
in Carlton House
Terrace, not far away.
Mounted and foot police;
however, blocked the way
at a respectable distance
and stopped the crowd.
>> Litzinger: CBS
news correspondent,
Richard C. Hottilice, the last
of the famed Murrow boys
hired to cover the war,
remembers a reporter
in the field pretty much started
talking at an agreed upon time
and hoped that, somehow, the
broadcast actually made it
to New York and got passed
through to listeners.
>> Hottilice: "We had a word
that you never hear anymore:
atmospherics, trying to
broadcast from the first army
in France and Belgium.
More than half the time
you couldn't get through.
What I'd do, you'd do your best,
and I'd get cables aimed
scheduling you for two minutes,
whatever it was, from so
and so and so and so to --
and you would appeal it.
There was sort of a
little one room studio run
by Press Wireless, which
I think was an off-shoot
of the New York Times.
You'd get there at the time
and you couldn't hear New York
or New York couldn't hear you
and if you couldn't hear New
York you went ahead anyway
at the appointed second, you
know, and if you start talking
up this is huddle it, --
you know, countdown go ahead
at ten seconds from now nine,
eight, seven, uh and go.
And on occasion, they heard you.
They picked it up and it
was fine, but you never knew
until much later, if at all.
>> Litzinger: The first
round had some glitches
and some dead air,
but it worked.
In fact it was such a success
they did it again the next night
and helped set the standard
for radio newscasts
for decades after.
An anchorman, they were
almost all men back then,
opened program, gave a
summary of what was to come
and what the main
news was, and then,
if the radio gods were smiling,
listeners would hear
amazing things: live reports
from thousands of miles away
where Americans were fighting
and dying, maybe their
son or their father
or husband or sweetheart.
>> Icy cold on the front
tonight and the mud on the roads
and in the fields is frozen
hard in wrinkles and folds.
The men, digging new positions
in the fields, have had to chop
up the ground with their
shovels and use axes.
And overall over ruined
buildings and [inaudible]
and the ruins of
[inaudible] over everything.
This late December
chill has brought a --
>> Litzinger: ask anyone old
enough to remember what it was
like to listen to a live report
from London during World War II,
it was a kind of miracle.
>> Ed Murrow: This
is Trafalger Square.
The noise that you hear
at the moment is the sound
of the air raid sirens.
I'm standing here
just on the steps
of St. Marten's in the field.
>> Litzinger: And if the first
world news roundup set the
standard, the man who became a
star made sure CBS's journalism
was first rate.
>> Ed Murrow: --
off in the distance,
one single beam sweeping
the sky above me now.
People are walking
along quite quietly.
We're just at the entrance
of an air raid shelter here
and I must move this
cable over just a bit
so people can walk in.
>> Litzinger: Ed Murrow
broadcast from rooftops
in London, reported from bombers
over Berlin, could barely speak
when telling the world what the
Nazis had done at Buchenwald.
>> Murrow: The doctor's
name was Paul Hellot.
He had been there since '38.
As we walked out into the
courtyard, a man fell dead.
Two others, they must
have been over 60,
were crawling toward
the latrine.
I saw it, but will
not describe it.
And in another part of the camp
they showed me the children,
hundreds of them, some were --
>> Litzinger: And it all began
with that first World News
Roundup March 13th 1938.
It had probably seemed
an impossible assignment,
find correspondents, make
sure they be near a microphone
at such and such time
ready to report the latest
on a world heading into war,
patch the relatively
primitive technology together
as best you could and let's go.
>> Bob Trout: This broadcast
from five world capitals
has been a presentation
of Columbia's Department
of Special Events
which will continue to cover the
European situation bringing you
special broadcasts and
bulletins as fresh news arrives
on this side of the ocean.
Tonight at 10:30
Eastern Standard Time,
Columbia presents its regular
Sunday night news broadcast,
Headlines and Bylines,
which, tonight,
will include the latest
summaries at that hour.
Bob Trout speaking, this is The
Columbia Broadcasting System.
>> Litzinger: The Roundup showed
and still shows what
radio news can do best:
report and make some sense of
a world that never stays still.
For the CBS News Weekend
Roundup I'm Sam Litzinger.
>> Sam Litzinger: So anyway
that's something that we did
with archival material
contemporarily.
We love anniversaries
in broadcasting
so anytime there's
an anniversary,
that's usually the
excuse to go back and find
out whatever we can get from
historical record and use that.
Michael?
Now -- [inaudible]
Almost none of it came
from the CBS archives.
I had in my own collection, I
had a lot of the Murrow stuff.
My favorite period of broadcast
journalism is World War II
so I have a fairly extensive
collection of stuff in there
and I do have them arranged
so that I can find them.
I mean I have Murrow
cuts individually labeled
and all that sort of stuff.
And then Hitler I think I just
got off YouTube basically.
YouTube -- you'll find
that probably for all kinds
of radio networks,
any historical material
like this -- YouTube.
That's where everybody
goes right now, so.
Originally, that was
all CBS's material
so there's not copyright
problems, I guess in that.
But, for some of the
historical material like,
and if it's in the public
domain you can use it
and that sort of thing.
But yeah, that wasn't -- I don't
think any of that was actually
from the secret CBS
audio archives.
So, which I don't know
where they are, so.
[Inaudible]
>> Shawn VanCour: Okay, I'm in
the unenviable position here
of being last so I feel
an obligation to try
to draw together some of the
things that I've heard here.
As Michael mentioned
I wear two hats.
I'm a trained media historian.
I also work in a program,
I teach archival studies.
So I have three
historiographical issues
that I see kind of running
throughout different
presentations here and two more
archival studies issues I'd just
like to flag that will
hopefully be helpful
for larger discussion.
So the first historiographical
issue is a question
of where we began.
I was interested to hear people
grappling with this question of,
for radio history, is what's
early radio going back
to Noah's question, right.
It's something I've dealt
with in my own work so,
traditionally, radio
history started
with the history
of the networks.
What if we pushed that back
into the pre-network period.
Film studies ran into a
similar problem, right?
So early film, for a long
time, that was the beginnings
of the studio system,
but then there's a lot
that happens before that, right?
How far back do we go?
Do we go back to the beginnings
of wireless telegraphy?
Do we go back, even if
we're thinking more media
archaeological approaches,
to imaginations of radio
or radio-like technologies
before those actually existed?
And then, you know, what do
we consider radio recordings,
in that case?
And this question,
related to that
of historical contextualization,
so, if we're talking someone
like Jack Benny or Eddie Canter,
then is radio history also
the history of something
like Vaudeville, right?
Is it the history
of film exhibition
if we're talking
someone like Roxy, right?
Is it the history of
print advertising?
Is it the history of the --
since many of these people were,
also, recording stars,
is it the history
of the phonograph
industry as well?
So, where do we start
our radio histories?
Where do we look, then?
Where we start depends, you
know, affects where we look.
And you know, then going back
to this question of network.
History versus alternative
history,
something we've heard a
lot in this conference.
The importance of
local community
of public broadcasting
histories.
As Alex was talking about,
I think those lines are
not always so easy to draw.
All network, I think here of, I
think Mark Williams has remarked
that all network stations are
also local stations, right?
And then we do have these
histories of collaboration
between network and you know,
culture of community
broadcasters.
There is the question of where
we look at the fragmentation
and dispersion of our
archival collections.
I'm not sure that's a problem
unique to radio history, right?
It's one that historians
always grapple with, right,
nothing is ever in
the same place.
But then, how do
you identify and get
at all those different
collections?
For radio, there is, one might
call it the paucity problem,
right, the lack of recordings?
Though, there, if
we think about --
I think one of the
things that's come
out of these talks is
alternative sources, right?
So we have print sources,
production records, scripts,
we also have -- and people often
mentioned, but policy documents,
license applications,
there's a lot of information
about our programming and
production methods there
and we also have, of course,
all of the trade presses,
the popular radio magazines,
the critics columns,
so there are other places
we can look for some
of this information to get
around that paucity problem.
And there is the discoverability
and access problem, there,
right, for discoverability.
Hopefully something like the
RPDF database helps a little bit
with that.
Finding where those
related materials are.
That access problem
being, in part I guess --
What we're supposed to be
accomplishing here, right?
How do we build the
collaborations between the folks
like -- the mythical CBS
archive, which we need
to talk more about, right --
to what extent does
this exist, right?
To some of these collections
that have been harder
to get our hands on in the past.
What do we look for?
It's sort of flipping this idea
of the program techs
on its head.
If we're doing histories
of commercial radio, right,
then this becomes --
we're looking for the
interstitial matter right,
as much as the main text.
And if we are looking
beyond strictly radio
and we're paying attention
to a lot of these performers
as intermedia stars or figures,
right, then, do the performances
in other media become every
bit as important, right?
So we need to listen to
those phonograph recordings
that have those radio artistry
and we need to watch the films.
And then on the archival
site side of things,
preserving these, right?
This question of appraisal
that you were talking
about, what do we save?
This is something that we
might want to discuss here?
What do we see as the
really important material
that we want to privilege?
Where do we put that, right?
That's always a question.
And how is that -- I think we
should make the distinction here
as well between preservation
and digitization, right?
That these are not
necessarily synonymous.
And then there is that
question of how people are going
to access that and
we start to get
into some copyright issues
there, but also, you know,
questions of resources.
How can you make that available?
And then this feeds
into my last point,
which is more a question,
I think, of outreach.
How do we share information
about these collections?
Scholarship is one
and education.
We have going on right
now as we're talking,
the education session, so we can
hopefully, based on what we come
up with here, then work with
the folks who've been discussing
these education issues and
think about how to work some
of these materials into
the curriculum in ways
that might depart from
the existing curriculum.
And then, something I think that
has been brought to the table,
too, with what you two
were talking about,
going with what Heather
was talking about earlier,
is the creative work, right?
That this is a great way
of exposing people to some
of these archival resources
and not just scholarship,
not just in the classroom, but
also through creative work.
So that's what I've got,
hopefully that helps get
some discussion going.
>> I saw the CBS
radio news archive.
>> Sam Litzinger: Where is it?!
>> I'll tell you
where it was in 1975.
I have a catalogue
of the disc portion.
Martin Werber was the CBS
radio archivist at that time.
Sam Serrat was the overall CBS
archivist, him I never met.
Martin took me in, and this
was at West 57th Street,
in the same place
where the radio
and Walter Cronkite's news
room and the Bolton room was,
that same part of
West 57th Street.
There was a cabinet in Martin's
office that was probably three
or four feet wide, four shelves.
That was the CBS discs for CBS
News and Martin did a catalogue
of those, it's about 60 pages.
I have, you know, a
Xerox of that catalogue.
In the next room, which
was a much larger room,
were all the tapes that
date back to the early '50s,
to at that point,
which was around 1975.
>> Sam Litzinger: And that
was all radio material?
>> That was all radio material,
none of the TV material
was there.
So that, you know, as
far as the entertainment,
what I know about the
entertainment archive I can't
say in public.
I'll talk to you later about --
>> Sam Litzinger: Great.
I'm sure it's a sad
story, but yeah, okay.
>> Yeah, about that.
My other aspect of
CBS is Kate Smith.
She was on the air from 1931
into the '60s at
least, in radio.
There was something like less
than seven complete one
hour Kate Smith programs.
There are seven of
the Kate Smith Speaks,
the fifteen minute noon
time program that she did.
When I started doing
the research
on God Bless America we found
that that program
does not exist.
None of the programs
from that era exist.
The choral director had the
Harry Smith recording studio
record the portions where
his chorus sang and Abbott
and Costello had Harry Smith
Studio record their routines.
And the choral director
stuff was eBay'd disc by disc
by disc a few years back.
When it came to the God Bless
America disc he wanted something
close to $10,000 for it,
and which infuriated
Michael Feinstein.
And Michael was able to
luckily notice that a dub --
and he didn't know it was a dub,
I figured out it was a dub --
a dub of that choral
director's disc was
in Irving Berlin's personal
library, which is at Rogers
and Hamm at Lincoln Center.
And so, now, I've inspected
that disc and I know
that it is a dub, comparing
it with the first minute
that we have of the
choral director's disc.
The Kate Smith fan club
director has about three
or four other recordings during
the next couple of months
of her doing God Bless America
so we were able to compare it.
The Irving Berlin papers
in this building show
that it had been
recorded every single week
for if people were
interested in it, his agent
or the music publisher
would send it out.
So we don't know -- all
Irving saved was the dub
of the first broadcast
November 10th 1938.
But it's you know, and the words
are different, it's on YouTube.
If the words are different
and if she does the
vocal introduction,
the spoken introduction
over a piano,
you've got the correct one.
If it's a video of her, you
don't, you have the recreation
from this as the Army.
That was posted by
Michael Feinstein,
it's under a pseudonym.
But it's amazing how little
of the important CBS
performers exist.
The stuff exists only
if they contracted
out to have it recorded
by independent studios.
I did a five and a
half hour broadcast
about God Bless America
and it's now available
on the web playing all
the different versions
that we do have, including
the one recording we have
of a closing of a
program from 1940
with her singing God
Bless America at the end
and the closing theme of,
first, When the Moon Comes
over the Mountain and it
segues into God Bless America.
So, it -- there's so
little of her stuff it's --
and believe me, they've
been looking for it.
>> Sam Litzinger: Yeah,
I'm afraid, I don't mean
to be overly cynical here,
but my guess is that,
if it costs money or it takes
time the media organizations
will not do it.
Or, they might be
willing to say, "Okay,
we'll spend some money
and we'll take some time
if there's something on
the other end for us.
If we can make a profit
off of this somehow,"
that might be incentive enough,
but it's just been my experience
that it's, again as
you were suggesting,
it's kind of a cultural thing.
Nobody really says, "You know,
we ought to be saving
this stuff," and it's --
[inaudible] yeah, but you
know, what happens is the sort
of thing that Mike has run into
where new management comes in --
I mean, the horror
stories I've heard
from the Lawrence-Tisch
take over of CBS!
It's like, he came
in and he said,
"Why would I want
this old stuff?
And why am I paying people
to keep this old stuff?
And why am I paying
for this room?
Get rid of this stuff!"
And it all just went away.
Right, and there are exceptions
to it, but unfortunately,
the rule seems to be if it's
going to cost you something
or take time, we're
not going to do it.
>> Michael Freedman: I'll just
put a positive quota on it --
>> Sam Litzinger:
Good, it's about time.
He'd used to do this
at CBS, too,
when I got overly
depressed about things.
>> Michael Freedman: One of
the Walter Cronkite Postscripts
to the 20th Century is on Kate
Smith introducing God Bless
America on her CBS
radio program.
I can't honestly tell you
whether the audio of her
in that capsule is
the original or not.
Perhaps it isn't, but the
moment is captured by Cronkite,
which is quite lovely to have.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Shawn VanCour: So
I think another thing
that you're pointing to
here, Mike, is the importance
of reaching out and I love that
we have had a whole panel on,
you know, transcriptions
at this conference, right?
Who has these recordings
now, right?
If they were not kept by
the original producers
and are reaching out to -- in
many cases as you mentioned,
right -- it may be
the fan communities,
the collecting communities,
right, who have that stuff
and who know about that, right?
So the importance of
really bringing them
into the conversation,
benefitting from their
expertise, right?
I wanted to also, just since
we got our mic back there,
for the folks up in the front
here who are on the panel
if you want to jump in --
>> Um, yeah.
>> Shawn VanCour: Great, great.
>> Okay, I'll keep it brief.
I'm, so this is really
interesting for me
because I'm a graduate
student and I study science
on television and most
of my dissertation work has
been focused on PBS programs
because that's just sort of the
access I've been able to get.
Although, there's some really
great shows done, which I want
to talk to you maybe
more about, but, like --
Walter Cronkite's
Universe, which is hard
to find, but it seems amazing.
My question is, again, talking
a bit about the, like, NBC, CBS,
ABC -- sort of on the executive
level, don't they all talk
to each other about how much
-- how great it would --
well, this is the
thing, I don't know, but.
Do they, themselves, they feel
like there should be
an equal sourcing?
I mean, are they concerned about
the narratives that are written
that don't include CBS or NBC?
>> Sam Litzinger: I'll let Mike
answer cause he was a manager
at CBS for a while.
>> Michael Freedman: No.
[ Laughter ]
>> Yeah and I will
just add to that,
that different institutions
have different cultures
about historical significance.
So every once in a while
you'll get lucky and you'll run
into an institution like
PBS that actually believes
in its institutional histories
being part of its legacy
and its value going forward.
But most media industries
consider their value
to be ahead of them, right?
So they have to be
future-thinking
and if they're thinking
about the past
that means they're
resting on their laurels.
Or else they're referring
to things
that might be embarrassing
to them in the present
or definitely don't
make them look
like they're forward
future-thinking.
So my experience has been
that very few media
institutions think that way,
so NBC did deposit a
bunch of its records,
but then they stopped
doing that, right?
Anybody correct me if I'm wrong.
They've stopped sending stuff
to Wisconsin to preserve
for historians to
continue using.
J. Walter Thompson is the
only ad agency that I'm aware
of that has saved its records
and deposited them at Duke
and they continue to deposit
new records regularly there,
so in fact they keep growing.
Because they're the only
ad agency that I'm aware
of that think that it's
legacy is not only valuable,
but reflects well on itself.
So, other agencies
their records are gone.
>> Michael Freedman: NBC also
burned the earl kinescopes
of the early Tonight
Show to make room
on the shelf, so
it cuts both ways.
One person who deserves
a real shout
out at CBS is Jeffrey Fager,
Jeff Fager is the producer
of 60 minutes and he was
the chairman of CBS News
at a very pivotal
time in its history
over the last 10-15 years.
He is a person who cares
about CBS's history
and has worked hard
to preserve it.
He also looked for
ways to monetize it,
which were a little
bit more difficult,
but Jeff is a really good
man and, most recently,
Jeff has commissioned research
through a lovely young
man named Sasha Reuther,
for a new retrospective of the
Murrow Boys, which is based
on the Stan Cloud and Lynne
Olson book of the same title.
So, a real shout out to
Jeff Fager at CBS News.
>> Sam Litzinger: By the
way does anybody know
if NPR has an archivist?
They do? They do?
Okay, they actually have full
time archivists who do that?
I was just curious.
And how accessible was NPR's
material to you scholars?
Okay. Alright.
>> I have two points, the first
is probably blasphemous for some
of you collectors, here
but, in building an archive
of local media, I'll take
any recording I can get.
I don't care if it's a dub.
I'd rather save that than
limit myself to an original
and not have anything.
So that's my blasphemous point.
My second point for Mike and for
Sam, I was on KMOX in 1979-83
as an announcer and after
my retirement they asked me
if I'd be their unpaid
historian, whoopee.
I found a bunch of stuff,
but within the last year,
I got a grant at their request
to digitize their
audio archives.
CBS said, "We can't do it.
There's a third party involved
here," my charitable foundation,
"And we can't allow that."
My question for you, obviously
knowing that CBS radio is
about to be sold, I've got
an in there, but how is one
to approach this
kind of thinking,
where I have an archive
in the palm of my hand
and I've got the
funding to digitize it,
and corporate lawyers say,
"Oh you can't do that."
>> Michael Freedman: It's
a really great question
and interestly enough,
someone who wasn't able
to make the panel
today is Harvey Nagler,
who recently retired
as vice president
for CBS Radio Network News,
the person that brought me in,
that brought Sam in to CBS.
And Harvey and I spoike on
Wednesday and I asked him
that specific question.
I said, "You know, one
of the things that,
undoubtedly will come up is,
how do you access the material?"
And we both agreed that maybe
this is the wrong thing to say
in certain quarters,
but you don't work
through the attorneys.
You have to find,
and I said it before,
you have to find committed
executives who have the power
to make these things happen.
I think Jeff Fager is one of
the best people to come along
at CBS in the last 50 years.
He tutored under Don Hewitt
for many years at 60 Minutes,
so he has that sense of history
within him, but I think you have
to work within an individual.
Because to try and
breakdown the barriers
from the outside is
extraordinarily challenging
as you've found out.
If you have an angel on
the inside, it can happen.
You can make it happen.
>> I've got a quick Harvey
Nagler CBS News story.
An angel --
>> Sam Litzinger:
Is it a good one?
Okay, good, just checking.
>> I found a piece of audio
here at the Library of Congress
in the NBC friles that
I could prove was CBS.
And so I went and, Slate, I had
written an article for Slate
and the audio was really
key for the article.
And the librarians downstairs
said, "Oh what happened was,
when it was oversee stuff, RCA
just recorded the feed coming in
and didn't think about
it and threw it in there.
You know, they didn't think
of whether it was NBC or CBS.
And so I got the clip
and Brian Cornell, here,
in the Madison Building, said
to me, "You're going to have
to get the NBC permission.
That's all I can tell you, but
if people find out at CBS,"
and my article said it was CBS,
"You're going to be in trouble.
I'm just going to
tell you that."
So I got the NBC permission,
then I got the dub from here
and they told me to
contact Harvey Nagler.
And Iw as trembling, I
thought for sure this is going
to cost a fortune,
he's not going
to let me put this on the web.
I sent him an email, I
described it clearly,
and while I was doing an
education or whatever,
the email came back within 24
hours that said, "Go for it."
No charge, no anything,
just put it on there.
So.
>> Sam Litzinger: Yeah, well,
it's always been a mystery
to me why there isn't a
coororation, particularly
with academic institutions
and educational outlets and so
on it's just a mystery.
If it were up to me, you
could all have access
to anything we had, but
it just doesn't work
that way for some reason.
I guess because lawyers
are involved
with this stuff, I don't know.
>> I'm Karen Fishman,
I'm supervisor
of The Recorded Sound Research
Center and Brian is one
of staff members and I just,
too, want to sing the praises
of Harvey Nagler because
whenever we had a CBS --
so the library doesn't
own any copyrights.
So whatever we get -- if
somebody wants a copy they have
to -- our policy is they
have to get permission
from the rights holder.
Harvey always said yes.
Harvey was a joy and a
wonderful person to work with
and I just can't say enough
and maybe we should
contact Jeff Fager.
Maybe he'll be another
Harvey, I don't know,
but if you have some names of
people that we could contact
that would really help
the researcher community
because we're always -- we
need to have that information
so we can give it to people.
We want to give access --
we want to you, you know,
we want to give the
recordings we have,
that the library has, to people.
We don't want to just have it
here, you have to come here,
we want to give it -- but
we have to have permission
from the rights holders.
So, but I just wanted
to say, Harvey?
The best. So we really
appreciate all that he did.
>> Michael Freedman: Harvey
and I talk every week.
I'll be very pleased
to pass along all
of your nice comments
to him, thanks.
>> Hi, my name is Andrew Depuso,
I work for Manon
Archiving Services.
I don't have a lot of
experience in radio,
that's primarily why
I'm here and thank you,
it's been a great panel.
But I do work with some of the
television news organizations,
so I'm working with
FOX News in New York,
for instance, and some others.
But FOX specifically, has
just hired a managing director
for their archive, which I
thought was quite interesting
and he has taken an
active role in trying
to monetize their archive.
FOX, as part of this
initiative, did a survey.
And we know where
these tapes are.
And they've identified 2,000,000
tapes in their archive that are
at risk of going away.
A lot of the three quarter
inch are probably no good
anymore anyway.
So the reason they're doing
this, and I think the reason
that most broadcasters
are protective
of their assets is they
always feel there's going
to be some way to
monetize these even
if we don't know
what that is today.
So they don't want
to give out --
and before this I
worked for Sony Music
and I can tell you that's
exactly how they felt.
So, I guess my question
is, is there interest
in potentially finding ways
to monetize these archives
that you could bring to the
broadcasters and say, "Hey look,
podcasts, all the
rage these days,
why don't you start broadcasting
these things again and looking
for some way to get advertising
or other ways to monetize it,
so you know, you're
not basically looking
at something that's
going to rust."
I mean, old tape by
the way, is you know,
has got limited lifespan.
So it's either going
to become rust
in the not too distant future
or they're going to have
to find a way to
make money with it.
>> Sam Litzinger: Yeah,
I mean, that's a concern.
If they don't monetize this
thing pretty quickly it's going
to disappear and then they won't
have anything left to monetize
so that's a big concern, but.
Do you want to speak
to the other thing?
What could you do?
Or anybody else down
at the other end --
>> Michael Freedman: I
think it just goes back
to what this gentleman
mentioned from KMOX.
When there's third
party intervention,
there's immediate reluctance
to participate in it.
>> I'd just like to mention
that there are 750 episodes
of Jack Benny's radio show
available and it's not
because of NBC or CBS or
the advertising agencies,
it's completely due
to collectors.
The individual collectors
who got copies
of the transcription discs,
got the AFRS recordings,
and so it was them
sharing and trading tapes
that have created the -- I'm so
grateful for the bounty I have
for the performer
I've been studying.
But, it turns out that it's
due to fans, to collectors.
>> Sam Litzinger: Hey, Noah,
quick question for you.
Who was recording that early
stuff that you mentioned back
in the '20s and how
was it recorded?
>> Noah Arceneaux:
Actually, prior to 1920,
I can't remember the
gentleman's name,
but there was a German wireless
station in New Jersey --
yes, thank you, thank you.
This radio amateur was convinced
that the Germans were
hiding secret messages
within the Morse Code so
he recorded, I think it was
like on a cylinder, it
wasn't even like a disc.
Yeah, so there as a recording
of wireless telegraphy
and he was correct.
There were in fact
German messages hidden
in the Morse Code.
I don't know of any other
recordings from that era.
Are there other Morse Code --
[ Inaudible ]
>> Yeah, I just wanted
to make a comment
about the monetization issue.
Yeah, I mean I study
organizations
that are trying to
monetize culture.
The problem with
historical research, though,
is that when an organization
considers it
to be potentially
monetizable (phonetic),
that means that they don't
want to give anybody access.
And so it kind of destroys
efforts by archivists
and scholars to get access to
it because it gets locked away
until it gets lost,
stolen, or destroyed.
So it actually makes me really
anxious when I hear people talk
about trying to monetize, you
know, older media artifacts.
But I'm also, you know,
there's a conundrum,
which is that the stuff
is going to get thrown
out because it's too
expensive to maintain.
And so then the nonprofit world,
the educators, the archivists,
the libraries, the scholars
have to raise money to try
to preserve it, but that in
and of itself is not enough.
Because what often happens --
and I've been involved
in a particular case --
where the boxes are in a
warehouse in New Jersey,
but they're not going
to the archive even
though they were promised
because money has
to change hands.
And the private company
thinks it should be paid
for all of its records.
Whereas the archive thinks that
it needs to be paid in order
to catalogue these
thousands of documents.
And so since nobody has
the money and nobody wants
to spend -- the private
organization doesn't want
to spend the money and the
archive doesn't have the money,
they're just sitting
in the warehouse,
possibly until they get
thrown in the landfill.
And so if there's any
notion of monetization going
on in anybody's mind, I think
it tends to undermine the goal
of archivists and scholars,
which is just to preserve stuff
for the cultural, historical
legacy, not necessarily to try
to make a profit
off of artifacts
that no longer have a
profitable possibility
or potential anymore.
>> Sam Litzinger: Is there
any way around that, though?
Is there a solution to this?
>> I actually have an example
-- is anybody here familiar with
or worked with NBC Learn?
NBC Learn -- they
have it in Indiana?
Yeah, NBC Learn in
2011 signed a contract.
It's a unit of Universal,
although NBC's changed
hands, with Blackboard.
Any of you who teach,
did you see Blackboard
for about three years,
from about 2011-2013,
had a little column on the left
that said NBC Media Library.
And anybody -- you'd click on
it and it had amazing stuff.
It had the Hindenberg
Explosion, I mean, now,
anybody gets it from YouTube.
It had tons of great stuff
from the NBC archive.
The problem was when you
clicked on it from Blackboard,
they'd charge your institution.
So you had to get permission
from your institution.
That's an example of getting
around the monetization.
Somewhat for academic purpose.
I'm sure NBC wasn't
charging Blackboard
and the institutions what
Proquest or somebody else does.
>> Sam Litzinger: Well,
my question for you is
how did they get the stuff
from the NBC archives onto
the Blackboard website.
Somebody had to do that, right?
>> You can -- it's still live.
I don't know if the unit still
exists, but it's still live.
You can go to NBC
Live dot com --
>> Sam Litzinger: No I mean how
did somebody take the material
that NBC had and
transfer it over,
because some human being
had to do that, right?
Several human beings had --
>> I think it was just a shell.
I think NBC constructed --
>> Sam Litzinger: Maybe
somebody knows the answer.
>> I'm not sure if this
is completely relevant,
but when we -- so when somebody
wants something from NBC
from the library that
we have the archives,
we tell them they have to
get permission from NBC.
Many, many times NBC will
then put in an order,
they'll want what
they -- what we are --
what the person is asking
for because we charge
for the transfer, right?
So you'll get permission, but
NBC will then ask for a copy
for themselves, then
I think they were --
then they would give it to the
person who was asking for it.
They would give it
to them directly.
They would get a copy of
it, make a copy of it,
and then put it on
their website.
So I think they were
getting it from us.
They were being charged for
that and then putting it on.
I think that's how they got it.
>> Sam Litzinger: Okay,
yeah I just wasn't sure
because it sounds like somebody
actually has to do something,
which can be a problem
at networks
to get somebody to
actually do --
>> Well we were doing,
what we would do is,
we would make the
digitization of the recording,
send it to NBC, who
would then give it
to the researcher requesting it,
but then they would have
a copy for themselves.
So we would -- the Library of
Congress was doing all the work
for them, so to speak.
>> Sam Litzinger: We like it
when other people do the work --
>> So the Americna people, so
we charged them, so it wasn't
that your tax dollars
were going to NBC.
>> Just to go along with
this, I mean I'm always sort
of in this weird limital
state where I hear the desires
from collectors and
archivists and researchers
and then I hear the desires
of the media companies aside.
And just to add a little bit of
empathy, if you haven't worked
in a media company before.
This are incredibly
fortious places.
So you may work for CBS, NBC,
and you guys can correct me
if I'm wrong, but if you're
edecting your job isn't
to care for the archive.
You don't have a way to
care for the archive.
It's just, that's how it is.
And it can be horrifying
because you have your job
and then the next cubicle
over are the people
who should be saving what
you know should be saved
and you have no ability unless
you're higher up, to save it.
So, I just always like to
spell that out because I know
that it's easy to
demonize even --
I'm not going to
mention the Tisches --
but it's easy to
demonize the executives
who may have thrown
this stuff out,
but it's no doubt it
was not their decision.
>> Sam Litzinger: No,
It's my experience that's
absolutely correct.
What we do currently, is
at the end of the day,
one of the desk assistants,
if they think about it,
will file away some of the
major audio for that day.
Maybe a dozen cuts or something,
if Trump says something
important,
that will go into a little file.
Now, all of us who have access
to the CBS computers have access
to those files, but that's
not really historic material
in the sense that it's, maybe,
only five years old, maximum.
And occasionally they'll
put other things in there
as they think about it, but
there's nobody specifically
in charge of saying, "It is
my job at the end of each day
to take a certain number
of cuts and put them
into the archival file."
And if it, some days it just
doesn't happen, you know, so.
It's sort of hit or
miss, unfortunately.
>> Right, and that's why there's
been a real movement in terms
of film archives to really
systematize this stuff more --
and especially because the
media companies understood
that the assets were
worth a lot of money.
And so when they began to
realize there's a lot of money,
it was a lot more reason
to begin archiving things,
preserving them, conserving
them and making them accessible,
not for others, but
for disseminating
for Blu-Ray and streaming.
>> Noah Arceneaux: If
I could just jump in
and tell a sad story that I
could just kick myself for.
From '96 to about '99 I was
working on the CBS News website.
Originally, they called
it CBS News on the Web.
And even in '96, those of us
who worked there were
like, "This is a dumb name.
CBS News dot come, please."
And then, sure enough,
eventually --
the point is, I knew that what
we were doing was important
and I knew this was a
new media technology,
I didn't save any of it.
I didn't save screen
shots of any of it.
And all of that stuff is gone
and I now really look back
and regret, I was like, "Why
didn't I just take out a camera
and take a screen shot
of AOL on my computer?"
or whatever it was.
But there was no
one there thinking,
the present-ism we're always
looking for like Cynthia said,
who would ever want to
look at an old website?
Media historians exactly like
us, this would be valuable,
I just can't believe
I didn't save it.
>> Yeah, and I can add to that,
I did the exact same thing.
I worked on true mark
interactive websites,
never thought to myself,
this was 1998-1999,
I never thought it
should ve saved.
There was an organization
called Hollywood in Pixels,
which is now trying to go back
and preserve all the
digital media campaigns
that have been run
for the last 20 years.
Because nobody thought
of it, and you know,
I grant you neither one of us
had PhDs at that point to think
of that sort of thing, but
the reality is we still didn't
do it.
And so, maybe that's where
my empathy comes from,
because I guess you're
right, I'm just as guilty,
well maybe not just as guilty --
>> Alex Kupfer: So they're
preserving current campaigns
too, though?
>> My understanding is that
they are now trying to,
they have an awards
ceremony every year --
yeah, they are trying.
I don't know the actual efficacy
of sort of their archival thing,
but they are trying to go
back and do all that work.
All the way back to
things like the AI website,
which was quite innovative
back in the day, you know,
all those sort of campaigns.
But you're right,
and that's sort
of the position that
everyon'es in.
When you're running that fast,
especially when you're working
in a media company, it's only on
your subway ride home you think,
I really should save that.
Maybe you have that
conversation, most people don't.
They just gon on to the next.
>> Michael Freedman: I
think I'ts really important
to look for the hook.
That's what the broadcasters
are interested in.
Sam said it earlier,
we love anniversaries.
We did a lot of our
work together in the run
up to the millennium
celebration.
And the end of the 20th century
and CBS's role in broadcasting
in the 20th century
and in particular CBS
radio's role in it.
And that captured
people's attention.
But I will say, this
is just anecdotal, but,
the day we recorded
the third hour
of The CBS News 20th Century
Roundup with those Murrow boys
in the studio, Andrew Hayword,
who was then the president
of CBS News, came over
to the studio, went in,
and greeted Dick Kotalet
(phonetic) and Robert Trout
who was then 90 and all these
wonderful, wonderful people.
And then he came out and he put
his arm around me and he said,
"Thank God somebody
thought to do this."
That's what it comes down to.
It is.
>> Sam Litzinger: And
part of our problem is,
I think of networks sometimes,
particularly news organizations,
as sort of the Zen of all this.
We only live in the eternal
now and we don't tend to think
of much that happened before and
we rarely look into the future.
It's always, "Oh my
god a Trump tweet!"
And then the entire news
organization sort of moves
in that direction and
it's just a series
of these things that happen.
So, really, unless you have
somebody within the organization
who is thinking seriously
about preserving the history
or what do with the history
that we already have it
just doesn't get thought of.
That seems to be the
big problem for us.
>> Well, actually
I just want to add
that I think Trump
is coming back
to what I was saying
before about FOX.
I think that's a great example.
It comes back to that
point of monetization.
Right now, FOX News
and most people
who have intellectual
property of any kind see
that as a potential
to make money
and they're not about
ot give it up.
And FOX News is a good
example of that right,
because they have all this
FOX News video of Trump back
in the '80s hanging out with
Marla and doing all this stuff
and so all of these news clips
that were basically collecting
dust in Secaucus, New Jersey,
in one of their facilities,
now very valuable.
There's all sorts
of demand for it.
For that reason, they're coming
to us, we're digitizing this,
we're preserving it,
so if nothing else
from the FOX News
archive we will have Trump
preserved forever.
>> Sam Litzinger: Why
are they doing that?
Are they doing that for
news purpose or in the hopes
of selling some of that?
>> They're doing clip sales.
And Sony, by the
way I work for Sony,
so I've done work
with Sony Pictures.
Sony Pictures is now
doing this as well.
They see an opportunity to go
into the clip sale business.
And the internet and new
technology is making this
immensely easier than it
was just a few years ago.
So it's easy for them
to put up these clips,
monetize them pretty
easily, they sell it
by the two minute segments.
I mean they don't sell
much more than that.
But you know, you want
to do a thing on Trump,
you want something with
Marla, there you go.
Right? So they can
give you that sort
of thing out of their archive.
And I just, one last thing
about that, I also worked
with Sony Music and
there's not a record
that anybody had even
the remotest interest
in that hasn't been
digitized and restored
and preserved forever.
Because there was a profit
motive in all of that.
So, right now, what Sony
and Universal and the rest
of them are doing is
going beyond the records
that they had released
from the beginning of time.
And they're going to the stands,
they're going to the outtakes,
they're going to
the multi-tracks.
Calgary --
>> Sam Litzinger: Box
sets of things and --
>> Exactly right.
And now they're thinking, maybe
there's a way to monetize these.
So you know, that's the sort
of thing that's basically
taking place now.
>> Sam Litzinger: Interesting.
>> Shawn VanCour: I want to jump
in here while the mic's being
passed and just push back
against the -- it's easy to --
and I actually sympathize
with this
because I encounter this
all the time, right --
it's easy to lament
everything we don't have.
But I want to flip that on
its head and point toward --
I think, one of the things that
we've heard at the conference,
like, it's all of these amazing
collections we didn't know
about when we came hre, right?
Look at everything that's out
there that people aren't using.
So how do we get people
actually using the stuff that's
out there, right?
How do you find out about it?
How do you match the researchers
to the archives that --
how do you match the
educators with these archives?
So to just put a more
positive spin on this,
looka t all of the
history that is preserved,
let's get people using this.
>> You may be able to
stop kicking yourself.
I checked the wayback
machine nd there are entries
to CBS all the way back to 1997.
>> Noah Arceneaux: Many of
the images are broken now.
I've looked at that.
There's just this kind of
outline with some words
and I was like, "I know what
used to be on that page."
>> I've been curious about
this last couple of days.
The emphasis on public
broadcasting radio archives
and you know, as we heard at
the very beginning of this.
This is the token program
on commercial radio
and you know the focus has been
on the golden age of radio.
We're talking about the problem
of collecting radio today
and there are 14,000
radio stations, it's like,
we haven't heard much
in this conference
about collecting the -- you
know, commercial radio today.
Isn't that part of
our cultural heritage?
>> Sam Litzinger: Do they
still have logger reels?
Do you remember?
Does anybody know this?
>> It's all done digitally.
>> Sam Litzinger: It's
still an FCC requirement,
correct, is that?
It never was an FCC requirement?
For those of you who don't
know, back in the old days,
when I was starting in radio.
You had this thing that
was called a logger reel.
And it was a slow-moving,
gigantic reel.
And it would slowly turn
around and, in theory,
it recorded every single thing
that went out over the air
on your radio station
for that day.
Then at the end of the
day, the midnight guy had
to change the logger reels,
or however long it was.
Some of them would last
like three days or five days
or a week or something.
But then somebody pulled
them off and, theoretically,
they were stored some place.
And that was required at every
radio station I worked at up
until I joined the
networks in the early '80s.
>> I can add something
that I was going on now.
The major radio station
in Atlanta, Georgia,
it's been on the air
since about 1924,
I know some people
who work there.
They still have a
logging service.
It's not a tape anymore, it's a
digital wav recorder type thing.
And they're dumped after two
weeks or a month automatically.
And he told me, and he would
know, cause he's big in news
at that station, that the only
way anything is saved past
that is if he wants,
specifically, to save something
for his personal collection.
And that's the policy
from the legal department.
>> Sam Litzinger: So
maybe that's some answer
to your question, it's
not getting saved.
A lot of it is not
getting saved.
>> We did have our Born
Digital panel this morning.
Denver, you were on that,
did this come up at all
for current commercial content
or was it more podcast focused?
More podcast?
Okay.
>> Sam Litzinger: Yeah,
if you can get something
on the web it's likely to
live, but if you don't put it
on the web then it's
likely not to live.
It seems to me.
I started at this little station
in Titusville, Pennsylvania,
that used to save all
of its logger reels.
You know, and it had, like,
hundreds of these logger reels
and then the station got sold to
somebody and the truck pulled up
and they dumped it all
out and it's all gone.
So you know, if you don't
make a conscious effort
to save this stuff, it's
unlikely to get saved.
>> Alright, now I'm
Thomas Witherspoon.
I'm actually here representing
a project we're working
on called the Spectrum Archive,
The Radio Spectrum Archive.
I don't know how
many of you were
in the curation panel
yesterday or the forum,
but basically we've
been enthusiasts, fans,
have been making
spectrum recordings,
which are not an audio recording
of an individual broadcast
on an individual
frequency, but a recording
of the entire AM broadcast
band, for example, all at once.
>> Sam Litzinger: How
the heck do you do that?!
[ Inaudible ]
Oh.
>> Yeah, so you're -- yeah.
You're --
It's, yeah it's about
one and a half megahertz
to get the entire
AM broadcast band.
You can also do the
FM broadcast band,
shortwave bands,
and -- it's, pardon?
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah, yeah, it's
actually not that wide.
The archives, I mean,
the spectrum recordings
are quite large,
so they're not easy
to manipulate.
But, you know, for the past
two presidential elections,
for example, I recorded the AM
broadcast band as it was heard
in Asheville, North Carolina.
So during the day,
local stations.
At nighttime you could
hear things from all
across North America of course.
So you can go back now
with a software defined radio
application, take my file,
and you can tune through it
as if it were live radio.
It's all the radio
stations and the static
in between, everything.
And, so, that's one way around,
I guess, having a logger reel is
that people can make recordings
of more than just station.
>> Sam Litzinger: And what
are you doing with this?
>> Well, right now, I'm trying
to find a home for these files.
At home, right now, talk about
an endangered collection.
I have 50 terabytes
of recordings dating
back, for me, to 2011.
I've actually got recordings
that were made by other people
that date back all
the way to 1986.
In fact, one of the clips I
showed yesterday in the forum,
back in 1986, a radio enthusiast
in Providence, Rhode Island --
in fact, that's the recording
right there, he's bringing up --
that is an SDR application.
And this is, you
know, how it works.
It doesn't look like a
radio it looks like peace
of test equipment, but all
of those little peaks you see
on the line and the
waterfall display above,
that's what you call that;
those are all radio stations.
And it was recorded
on a VCR, a Hi-Fi VCR.
Someone tapped into the
intermediate frequency
on the receiver and
recorded it to the VCR
and then they actually
played back the VCR tape
through the radio.
Well, later, just a
couple of years ago,
he actually digitized this
so that we could play it
through an SDR application.
This is what it looks like,
I guess, if it can roll --
>> Sam Litzinger: And can
you find something specific
on this if you were looking?
>> Recording: -- there is no
way of knowing just how bad
that Chernobyl nuclear
plant disaster really is.
In the talk of the western world
there are still vast portions
of the Soviet Union that have
no idea that anything is wrong.
[Inaudible] with Stanford
University says the only people
in the Soviet Union
who were told
about Chernobyl are
in Moscow and Kiev.
We've been monitoring these
broadcasts since Tuesday,
there's been absolutely no
mention of anything connected
to a nuclear accident.
The Siberian people --
>> They actually narrate
in this just a little bit,
if you listen just
a little bit longer.
This is a recording that
you can tune through as
if it were live radio.
This is what the AM band
sounded like in Providence,
Rhode Island, on May 1, 1986.
I'll tune to another
frequency here.
>> Recording: -- in Europe
speaks told us all the European
leaders are still expected
to come to the summit
in Tokyo this weekend.
Vic Ratner, ABC News with
the president in Bali.
>> Sam Litzinger: Vic
Ratner's as old as the radio.
>> Recording: -- live from
the Kennedy Space Center
this evening.
It's the first launch there
since the Challenger
Space Shuttle explosion.
One Challenger investigator
says examination
of wreckage proves a
rocket joint failed.
Again pointing to a problem --
>> Sam Litzinger:
That's interesting.
The problem, though,
would be, I mean,
other than for scholarly
purposes, we couldn't use
that audio because
it's too terrible.
>> Yeah, exactly.
It's mainly, you know, for me
I would kind of classify myself
as a radio anthropologist.
So for me, this is very
context rich stuff.
You know. And right now we're
making the recordings because,
you know, a lot of us
believe that, you know,
through recording the AM
broadcast band's actually a
pretty diverse place.
Yeah, there's some big companies
in there that have a lot
of stations, but you
have community stations,
you have a lot of diversity and
you can, you know, later on, 20,
30 years from now,
scholars may want to go back
and see what it was like during
a period when people were trying
to discern between fake
and real news, for example.
But yeah, I just thought
I'd bring that up --
>> Sam Litzinger: I didn't
even know that existed.
>> Shawn VanCour: If you're
sending it to us for broadcast,
too, isn't that atmospherics
part
of the broadcasting
experience, right?
>> Sam Litzinger:
You get forgiven
if it's 1942 as opposed to 2017.
>> And that's actually --
we're actually out of time.
That's actually a
great place to end
because we spent all this
time on these missing archives
and the problem with CBS --
>> You know what nobody
mentioned in here?
Nobody mentioned ABC.
Nobody ever mentions ABC.
No, but there's the
Roone Arledge book --
there's something going on
there that's totally separate,
but we end it with somebody
who's rescuing commercial radio.
Which, I'm very glad
you volunteered
that because here we
have all the problems
with the monetization,
the profit, this and that.
And we have people who are
actively engaged and energized
to save something that the
companies themselves don't seem
to even recognize in that way.
So that's a very
positive, Shawn,
you were looking for positive.
What a positive way
to end the panel.
Alright, thank you very much.
And thank our participants,
and this is terrific.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.